there he is the little dude activate
dude we're still working on him i worked
on him myself he's perfect dropping dude
now
[Music]
who are you catchphrase catchphrase well
that don't think one up yet although
catchphrase catchphrase is a pretty cool
catchphrase
am i a role model i don't know
i mean i do know that you hear about
actors complaining about how hard their
movie workouts are
and i'll tell you i don't have time for
that i've been at this one week
and i gotta tell you it's coming in
nicely
i start every day with a protein bomb
it's made exclusively of
human muscle it's completely organic
and illegal acting is
mind over matter and judgment
and common sense
sure i don't fit into the deadpool suit
anymore
but life is about growth hormones
[Music]
well i actually fathered our youngest
daughter when i was this muscular
[Music]
the child was born full-grown
[Music]
and wearing shoes
which was weird for blake
[Music]
who is this i don't know i mean he's
just like you but way better
with the movie i think he's gonna hit
you
he punches so hard but yeah his hands
are so soft
you